die große generaldebatte sie geht gleich
los deutschland im krisenmodus und wir
werden gleich kanzler olaf scholz und
auch friedrich merz herne das duell und
jetzt bei uns im studio begrüßen wir
bild politikchef ich ein schäfer schön
dass du da bist ja guten morgen guten
morgen so jetzt ab 9 muss sich ja die
bundesregierung im bundestag
ihre politik der letzten monate
verteidigen es wird ein harter
schlagabtausch erwartet zwischen kanzler
scholz und vor allem friedrich merz was
was können wir da erwarten wir sind
natürlich dankbare themen akw
verlängerung der krieg in der ukraine
dann haben wir unter anderem auch noch
das entlastungspaket was erwartest du da
wie hart wird das für das
wiwi wie hart wird das vonstatten gehen
so also traditionell ist das was wir
gleich erleben werden eine sternstunde
des parlaments der oppositionsführer
friedrich merz und da wir jetzt auch
direkt hin genau und dann sehen wir
gleich mal wie es hieß war da geht
der russischen politik
nach dem ende der sowjetunion geblieben
dann wären nicht nur die russische
geschichte anders verlaufen
die gesamte europäische geschichte wäre
anders verlaufen
aber spätestens seit dem russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine sind wir
auf schreckliche weise mit einer ganz
anderen realität konfrontiert und diese
realität hat folgen für ganz europa aber
auch und ganz besonders für deutschland
wir haben seit ihrer regierungserklärung
herr bundeskanzler am 27 februar über
diese folgen oft und intensiv diskutiert
wir haben gemeinsame entscheidungen
getroffen bis hin zu einer änderung des
grundgesetzes
und einer gemeinsamen entschließung des
deutschen bundestages am 28 april über
umfassende humanitäre finanzielle und
militärische hilfe für die ukraine
mit diesen beiden
entscheidungen enden dann aber auch die
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen ihrer regierung
und ums soweit der bundeshaushalt
betroffen ist über den wir in dieser
woche in erster lesung beraten
hatten sie ihre eigene zusagen nicht ein
der bundeskanzler der bundeswehr zitat
sie erinnern sich möglicherweise ab
sofort jedes jahr ab sofort jedes jahr
mehr als zwei prozent des bip für
investitionen in die bündnisse und
verteidigungsfähigkeit zur verfügung zu
stellen der bundeswehr etwa hätte neben
den 100 milliarden euro die wir zusammen
geschlossen haben jahr für jahr
ansteigen müssen stattdessen kürzen sie
von diesem jahr auf das nächste jahr den
etat um 300 millionen euro
herr bundeskanzler wir müssen es leider
feststellen wir können den von ihnen
gegebenen zusagen nicht vertrauen
neben den rein finanziellen fragen der
ausstattung der bundeswehr kommen sie
und ihre regierung auch der eindeutigen
aufforderung des deutschen bundestages
vom 28 april nicht nach die ukraine in
ausreichendem maße mit schweren waffen
zu versorgen und fällt niemandem von uns
leicht zu verstehen dass der einsatz von
waffen den frieden näher bringen kann
aber lassen sie mich vielleicht zitieren
aus einem interview lassen sie mich
zitieren aus einem interview dass einer
der renommiertesten national und
international anerkannten
politikwissenschaftler unseres landes
vor zwei wochen in der berliner zeitung
gegeben hat es ist herfried münkler er
sagt ich bin erstaunt über die naivität
eines teils der intellektuellen szene
und mancher politiker in deutschland die
offenbar glauben dass putin an den
verhandlungstisch kommen wird wenn man
ihn dazu auffordert das gegenteil ist
der fall
russland so sagt er muss durch
militärische misserfolge zu gesprächen
mit der ukraine gezwungen werden werden
mit waffenlieferungen aus dem ausland
beschleunigt man also einen prozess an
dessen ende verhandlungen stehen
in deutschland
gibt es offenbar keine kultur des
militärisch strategischen denkens
deswegen werden diese aus expertensicht
absurden forderungen nicht als falsch
erkannt der weg so schließt er an den
verhandlungstisch wird einzig über
militärische erfolge der ukraine die
russland die aussicht auf den großen
sieg neben ende des zitats der
bundeskanzler
[Applaus]
friedrich merz der cdu-chef und
fraktionschef der versucht es jetzt zu
beginn seiner rede sehr sehr
staatsmännisch hält olaf scholz den
spiegel vor und ist zuerst beim thema
ukraine und sagt ganz klar das was die
regierung bisher geleistet hat das
unterscheidet sich massiv von dem was
sie angekündigt hat viele waffen bahn
angekündigt und wenig ist bisher nur
geliefert worden dann ist die
zögerlichkeit der
ukraine noch intensiver zu helfen einen
grund dafür dass dieser krieg sich
verlängert er fordert noch mehr opfer
auf beiden seiten als dieser krieg
ohnehin schon gefordert hat die länge
dieses krieges verschärft auch die
wirtschaftliche lage in deutschland und
in europa wir müssen heute meine damen
und herren davon ausgehen dass vor allem
deutschland aufgrund seiner ich sage
ausdrücklich nicht von dieser regierung
allein zu verantwortenden
energieabhängigkeit von russland in
besonderem maße von diesem drohenden
versorgungsengpässen
ich habe es doch gerade gesagt
ausdrücklich nicht von ihnen allein zu
verantworten
dass ein spannender punkt und da gibt es
auch wie wir gerade schon gehört haben
jubel im bundestag friedrich merz
attackiert die bundesregierung sagt sie
haben diese energiepolitik
mitzuverantworten nicht allein denn klar
ist natürlich die abhängigkeit von
russischen gast die geht vor allem und
ganz besonders auch auf das konto von
der ex bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und
die ist wie wir alle wissen cdu-mitglied
genau wie friedrich merz
fehlt dieser bundesregierung jede
fähigkeit zum politisch strategischen
denken
sie mühen und streiten sich über wochen
und monate die gesamte sommerpause ist
doch bestimmt gewesen von einem
permanenten streit dieser koalition über
wochen und herausgekommen ist wieder
einmal ein sammelsurium an kompromissen
auf dem niveau des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners den diese koalition noch
zusammenhält weit davon entfernt weit
davon entfernt
sachgerechte antworten auf diese
gewaltigen herausforderungen zu gehen
vor denen wir stehen und lassen sie mich
meine damen und herren beginnt mit einer
rein formalen frage der frage der
zuständigkeiten spätestens diese krise
und das durcheinander in ihrer koalition
hätten sie herr bundeskanzler zum anlass
nehmen müssen im bundeskanzleramt einen
energie sicherheitsrat noch besser einen
nationalen sicherheitsrat aus
mitgliedern der bundesregierung und
experten von außen einzurichten
spätestens diese krise wäre veranlassen
gewesen die zuständigkeit an sich zu
ziehen wenn sie können die hoch
komplexen fragen der energiepolitik und
der versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
in einer solchen existenziellen krise
doch nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann den wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen wer aber
umgeben ist ja aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aussicht auf erfolg hat
diese these in den raum
und mit verlaub wie hilflos er habe sie
in diesen fragen sind das konnte man
gestern abend im deutschen fernsehen
beobachten man kann nur hoffen man kann
hoffen dass
ein großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen unternehmer und vor
allem der bäckerinnen und bäcker um
diese uhrzeit schon im bett gelegt haben
und geschlafen haben um das nicht mit
ansehen mussten was sie da gestern abend
von sich gegeben hat man kann das nur
rufen
[Musik]
ja friedrich merz geht auf das ein was
zuschauer von bild live seit stunden
hier schon sehen können es geht um
robert habeck es geht um seinen auftritt
gestern bei maischberger und der frage
wann ist eine firma eigentlich insolvent
in der tat da hat friedrich merz jetzt
einen klassischen punkt gemacht gab
entsprechend viel beifall auch von
seiten der cdu csu fraktion in robert
habeck hat sich ganz ganz schwer getan
gestammelt geschwatzt und wusste nicht
wann eine firma pleite ist das hält ihn
der
cdu/csu-fraktionschef jetzt wollen wir
sehen die debatte gewinnt an fahrt das
ist genau das die sternstunde der
politik im bundestag sie hat begonnen
viele unternehmen viele unternehmen in
deutschland haben die auftragsbücher im
augenblick so voll wie schon seit jahren
nicht mehr aber sie können diese
aufträge nicht abarbeiten sie geben sie
zurück weil die lieferketten
unterbrochen sind weil die preise durch
die decke gehen und weil sie nicht mehr
in der lage sind die aufträge
abzuarbeiten diesen schon seit längerer
zeit in den büchern stehen haben das hat
etwas mit der inflationsrate und der
geldentwertung und den lieferketten zu
tun schauen sie sich das doch bitte in
ihren wahlkreisen einmal an jeder von
uns bekommt jeden tag nachrichten und
briefe aus den unternehmen die genau auf
diesen sachverhalt hinweisen und sie
gehen mit einer bemerkenswerten ignoranz
über dieses thema hinweg und nur über
hilfsprogramme hat einmal das thema
wirklich an der wurzel zu packen
sucht man sichtbar in ihrem papier von
vergangenen sonntag nach lösungen zu
diesem problem stößt man vor allem
gratulation an die fdp dass sie die
kalte progression abbauen wollen meine
damen und herren das steht im gesetz
dass sie das ohnehin machen müssen und
sie sind dazu verpflichtet diese frage
alle zwei jahre zu klären und es gibt
doch zumindest eine moralische
verpflichtung das jetzt zu tun und nicht
erst im jahr 2023 sondern jetzt im jahr
2022 wäre die richtige antwort im jahr
der krise gewesen diese entscheidung zu
treffen
stattdessen stattdessen halten sie fest
stattdessen halten sie fest an der
gasanlage die zum ersten oktober nun in
kraft treten sollen diese gasanlage wird
die inflationsrate in deutschland noch
weiter in die höhe treiben sie wird die
privaten haushalte noch höher belasten
und sie wird vor allen dingen die
unternehmen in deutschland zu einem
zeitpunkt wo sie nun überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen können mit tausenden
hunderttausend millionen zusätzlicher
kosten belasten nur weil sie
ein friedrich merz hat natürlich jetzt
leichtes spiel viele dinge laufen falsch
viele dinge hat robert habeck und hat
die ampel regierung verbockt und
friedrich merz versucht auch einen
weiteren trick versucht einen keil in
die ampel zu treiben dem er ganz bewusst
die fdp für ihre finanzpolitik für ihre
steuerpolitik lobt weil sie die
sogenannte kalte progression abbauen
möchte zum ersten januar 20 23 und dafür
kritik von spd und grünen erntet also
klassisch der oppositionsführer treibern
hat es natürlich auch leicht weil er
nicht regieren muss und versucht die
ampel zu speisen
während der korona krise einmal gemacht
haben dies ist die systematik die
instrumente sind vorhanden sie weigern
sich auf diese instrumente zurückgreifen
weil sie mit dem kopf durch die wand
wollen und eine einmal geschlossene
entscheidung nicht zurücknehmen wollen
das die wahrheit mit dieser karte markt
kommt
nun kommt das meisterstück dieser
regierung nämlich die entscheidung vom
montag dieser woche über den
atomausstieg ich meine damen und herren
zunächst einmal vor der klammer damit
das klar ist natürlich muss man den
menschen in einer solchen situation
helfen wenn die energiepreise steigen
wenn die privaten haushalte hoch
belastet sind muss man helfen und sie
haben durchaus in dem papier vom
vergangenen sonntag einige wichtige
beschlüsse gefasst ich nenne ihnen war
nur 200
sie beschweren sich doch darüber dass
wir zu viel kritisieren jetzt sage ich
mal etwas sage ich ihnen etwas wo sie
richtig liegen sie haben gottseidank
gesehen dass sie die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die studierenden in
deutschland übersehen haben bei dem
letzten hilfspaket und korrigieren das
jetzt aber ein bundeskanzler jetzt mal
ganz im ernst 300 euro für jeden
haushalt sie und ich bekommen das in
diesen tagen auch überwiesen
brauchen sie das brauchen wir das oder
gibt es vielleicht in diesem land
haushalte mit einem
durchschnittseinkommen von vielleicht
1500 1600 euro im monat netto
so jetzt natürlich schlau wenn friedrich
merz sich noch als gutmensch wirklich
generieren wird und sagen würde und wir
von der cdu csu fraktion wir spenden
diese 300 euro hat er bisher nicht
gemacht ist glaube ich ein fehler wäre
jetzt ein ball auf dem elfmeterpunkt wie
man im fußball sagen würde friedrich
merz hat den bisher noch nicht
verwandelte weise etwas zu sehr in den
hintergrund getreten ist die
entscheidung den tarifvertragsparteien
das angebot zu machen ein einmalbetrag
von 3000 euro zu verabreden der dann
steuer und abgabenfrei ist ist richtig
und ich will von dieser stelle auch den
tarifvertragsparteien sagen nehmen sie
dieses angebot in anspruch damit sie
jetzt möglichst schnell den privaten
haushalt mit einer solchen einmalzahlung
helfen das ist eine richtige
entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
aber meine damen und herren das sind
doch alles
das sind doch alles reparaturen an einem
problem das sie in der wurzel nicht
anfassen wir haben es mit dieser
gaspreisentwicklung mit einem
klassischen
angebotsschock zu tun was macht man wenn
man einen solchen angebots
schockerlebnis dann versucht man doch
zunächst einmal darauf zu reagieren
indem man alle möglichkeiten nutzt das
vorhandene angebot das immer noch zur
verfügung steht auszuschöpfen und zwar
mit ganzer kraft und jede möglichkeit zu
nutzen
das nennt man meine damen und herren das
nennt man marktwirtschaft der ein oder
andere wird diesen begriff von ihm schon
mal gehört haben so hergibt man in einer
marktwirtschaft auf einen angebotsschock
und diese reaktion wäre richtig gewesen
im hinblick auf die gesamte palette der
energieversorgung die wir in diesem
lande haben stattdessen wird in dieser
regierung weiter verzögert herum laviert
verhindert und wertvolle zeit vergeudet
ich nenne ihnen ein beispiel beispiele
da sind die steinkohlekraftwerke dem sie
erst die betriebserlaubnis geben wieder
hochzufahren wenn für mehrere wochen die
reserven auf dem hof liegen das gilt für
die biomasse wir haben hier darüber
gesprochen sie wollten den deckel
aufheben der ist bis heute bei 1000 mw
gedeckelt es nach wie vor vorhanden aus
biomasse könnte das zehnfache an strom
gewonnen werden was wir heute unter
diesem deckel liegen haben das geht
das geht hier die braunkohlekraftwerke
von denen immer noch einige blöcke
stillstehen und das ergebnis ist dass
wir im jahr 2022 mehr gas verströmt
haben als in vielen jahren vorher wir
sind in einem land in die in einer zeit
in der gas gespart werden muss
gespeichert werden musste
was auch immer da gerade passiert es aus
bei robert habeck auf dem telefon
geklingelt hat oder eben auch nicht
friedrich merz rechnet jetzt vor allem
mit robert habeck bisherige
energiepolitik ab sagt das was die ampel
eigentlich wollte nämlich
kohlekraftwerke hochzufahren und für
energiesicherheit strom sicherheit zu
sorgen da ist bisher ganz ganz wenig
passiert und ausgerechnet jetzt und wir
haben es gerade im bild gesehen gut
eingefangen ist der platz von robert
habeck auf der regierungsbank
aber meine damen und herren was da am
montagabend was da am montagabend
verkündet worden ist das beruhigt
möglicherweise die grüne basis vor allem
in niedersachsen in wahrheit halten sie
mit dieser politik das ganze land zum
lachen und beschädigen möglicherweise
unwiderruflich die deutschen unternehmen
den gesamten wirtschaftsstandort und vor
allem die mittelständischen unternehmen
in unserem land
damit
meine damen und herren damit dass von
dieser stelle aus klar wird weil sie das
hin und wieder auch anders in
deutschland verbreiten niemand von uns
will zurück zur alten kernenergie
[Applaus]
also vielleicht muss ich so für sie
vielleicht muss ich für sie noch mal
wiederholen damit sie es verstehen
niemand von uns will zurück zur alten
kernenergie die wir 2011 in deutschland
beendet haben aber in einer gewiss nicht
[Applaus]
die ganze die ganze ignoranz zu diesem
thema die steht ihnen ins gesicht
geschrieben wenn man von dieser stelle
aus wenn man von dieser stelle aus
strick
wir haben wir haben in deutschland
wir haben in deutschland noch drei
laufende kernkraftwerke das sind die
modernsten und sichersten
kernkraftwerke der welt die ganze welt
drum herum schaut auf deutschland und
draußen sagen die leute sind diese
deutschen eigentlich verrückt geworden
in einer solchen situation drei
kernkraftwerke stillzulegen die in der
lage wären zehn millionen haushalte
sicher mit strom zu versorgen
meine damen und herren das ist doch das
ist das hat doch ein niveau an die
nationalität erreicht das kann man doch
gar nicht mehr beschreiben wir haben
ihnen das angebot gemacht in den
sommerferien eine sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestages durchzuführen mit
einer änderung des atomgesetzes
wir hätten mit ihnen gemeinsam den weg
gegangen dies für drei oder vier jahre
zu ermöglichen nicht mehr aber bitte
auch nicht weniger aber das was sie
jetzt da machen ist doch ein fauler
kompromiss die beiden atomkraftwerke die
nach ihrem willen im standby betrieb
bleiben sollen und alle fachleute sagen
ihnen dass das hochgradiger unfug ist
das zu machen müssen die komplette
mannschaft vorhalten bleiben am netz
sollen hochgefahren werden wenn wir ein
problem in deutschland habe ich sage
ihnen wir werden
nur ein problem habe ich sie haben vor
einigen wochen mal gesagt wir hätten
keinen strom problem wir hätten ein gas
problem wir sind mittendrin in einem
massiven stromproblem in diesem land und
sie haben es offensichtlich bis heute
nicht verstanden dass es so ist wenn sie
wenn sie dafür sorgen wollen dass die
preise runtergehen in deutschland dass
die hilfsmaßnahmen die wir gemeinsam
vielleicht ergreifen müssen nicht
überborden und den haushalt
überstrapazieren dann muss man auf der
angebotsseite alles tun damit genug
strom damit genug energie in diesem
lande verfügbar ist und das ist keine
frage der netzstabilität die hat sie
haben prüfen lassen das ist eine frage
der stromerzeugung kapazitäten in
deutschland regen sie sich mal nicht auf
die parlaments ärztin ist da wenn sie
wollen wir gleich gehen
also nur eines zu sagen bei eines zu
sagen denn sie wenn sie mit ihrer
fraktion der meinung sind diese probleme
die wir jetzt haben zum gegenstand von
auseinandersetzungen auf den straßen in
deutschland machen zu wollen dann werden
wir ihnen mit allem was wir haben und
notfalls mit allen anderen zusammen im
parlament entgegen treten wir werden es
nicht zulassen dass sie dieses land mit
ihrer politik de stabilisieren das
werden wir nicht
und was machen wir dann nochmals in
allen anderen fächern und verhindern
dass sie da ihr braunes kunstepochen
nein meine damen und herren herr
bundeskanzler
ich will es ihnen auch wirklich sagen
für laufzeit muss diese kapazität am
netz bleiben damit senken wir die preise
damit senken wir die kosten für die
unternehmen damit schaffen wir
planungssicherheit auch für die
unternehmen in deutschland und ich will
sie aufrufen die lage spitzt sich in den
nächsten tagen wochen und monaten
möglicherweise dramatisch zu und sie
wissen es sie haben die gesprächspartner
die ihnen das gesagt haben es dürfte
alles andere als eine übertreibung sein
ich sage ihnen herr bundeskanzler
stoppen sie diesen irrsinn aus ihrer
koalition so lange wir die zeit dafür
noch haben herzlichen dank
ja es war eine kämpferische rede zum
ende hin von friedrich merz er hat auch
noch mal gegen die ennahda afd gelindert
ganz ordentlich hat dafür applaus auch
von den anderen parteien bekommt kern am
ende seiner auseinandersetzung mit der
regierung bin robert habeck vor allem
war die energiepolitik ganz klar die
message die botschaft von friedrich merz
die drei verbliebenen kernkraftwerke
sollen müssen am netz bleiben damit
deutschland einigermaßen sicher durch
den winter kommt er hat da den
bundeskanzler aber vor allem hat er den
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck über
die ganze rede hin immer wieder massiv
attackiert robert habe ich verließ auch
kurzzeitig seinen platz und jetzt ruft
die bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
den bundeskanzler ans mikrofon wir
dürfen gespannt sein
[Musik]